there's a disease spreading through are
you a disease plaguing pathetic beta
males people attempting self-worth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop it uh speedrunning the concept of
playing a game slightly faster than
someone else excuse me
playing a game that no one else is
playing slightly faster than no one
excuse me you must be new on this
channel okay first of all number one
I never scream like a man-child does not
happen second of all I have never died
in a video game in my entire life
jump what's wrong zere row death and
third of all that's about it actually
for real
speedrunning can be sometimes very cool
and very impactful and emotional look at
this [ __ ] line I take I'm like yeah
baby [ __ ] do this I wait I wait I
wait
right when he starts firing to try to
backboost me the double body armor two
quick ones already know I'm getting
there on the fur fly look at the [ __ ]
face
49
[Music]
and sometimes a kid speedruns can just
be impressive and interesting to watch
just seeing someone really good at a
video game Jesus Christ oh my god are
you kidding me I could have got that
yeah he definitely made a mistake there
what a loser I would not have made a
mistake stop stop this game took me
weeks he definitely made a mistake there
wow I just I just see so many made
mistakes happening here this is actually
painful to watch I'm cringing so much
right now
we got it we got the sub - we did it god
damn it god damn these people and
sometimes it can just be really
emotional okay oh my god the problem
begins as always with the sold the tasty
tasty salt imagine playing the same game
literally from month in and out things
aren't going the way you want it to be
you're not getting that record that you
so badly want well that's that's when it
gets good that's when it gets really
good
[Music]
hey I got hundred-twenty sorry Mario -
[Music]
it's a video game
see I would never get mad at a video
game that's just ridiculous the salt
it's just it's a fine salt what's the
point of playing a video game when
you're not having fun you might ask well
you need to set that record you need to
be faster than anyone else Jesus Christ
he just became an auditor what is that
sound
this this might be one of my top at
least top five best screams of all time
just sit just enjoy but do
[Music]
it's the pure terror in the screech it's
so wonderful
[Music]
[Music]
so has he played for an hour and a half
and then he failed and the whole thing
is over I can I could kind of understand
this one to be some speedrunners have
however become self-aware how many hours
of my life have I wasted playing this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] goddamn game just
so i can get world records and feel good
about myself it's a [ __ ] joke that's
the only reason people speedrun really
it's so I can like get a world record
cuz like you know no one who speedruns
is a [ __ ] millionaire you know
[ __ ] hot [ __ ] and like doing
actually important things in life
everyone speedruns is a degenerate and
getting world records the way they can
feel good about themselves yeah like how
many [ __ ] hours of my life I wasted
doing that [ __ ] it's so stupid it's
[ __ ] pathetic all I [ __ ] do is
waste my life away trying out world
records for a temporary goddamn high
what to last
[ __ ] you know a week or so until it
goes away and ace exposes me for the
world record [ __ ] I am [ __ ] hell
dude bad joke speedrunning is the most
degenerate act man has ever come up with
well you heard it here first
speedrunning is the most degenerate act
men can commit so we [ __ ] speedrun
cuz it gives us this temporary feeling
of like oh my god I'm good
ten I'm the best in the world it at this
thing that like hardly anyone else does
that's all it is
[Music]
we're all a [ __ ] joke Mykel we
masquerade around agdq like haha we're
so cool for cancer take a deep breath
pause the game go up say that's all you
have to do it's the eyeball run
everybody truly pathetic disgusting
despicable behavior this is impossible
it's impossible everybody this is not a
speedrun but I love how this guy just
turns into a [ __ ] blowtorch
[Applause]
I get it I get some bits of it but
getting this upset about a game is not
it's not healthy take it from someone I
used to be addicted to video game I can
see the same tendencies and it's time
it's time to stop take a good deep look
at yourself and what you're doing and
what you're spending your time on is it
really worth it is it really bringing
you joy and happiness now know
everyone's gonna hate on me for [ __ ]
on speedrunning money for a good cause
to play games that's right so that's why
I'm going to show you how easy it is to
speedrun one of my favourite games of
all time
[Music]
all right here we go come on oh my god
come on come on I can do this man
Oh gasps that looks great let's see I
think I'll go with yeah that looks good
yeah I like that color
let's see
oh this is the water record I would be
amazing that would finally make me happy
there you go
if this gets the world record guys
finally my life will have some sort of
meaning and purpose and remember this is
for the kids guys please donate dammit
it's never done that
it's a world record everybody thank you
told you I told you I'm good at games
now that's my case closed thank you guys
for watching leave a like for no reason
at all and I'll see you guys in the next
one goodbye